[Music]
first learned about this seven years ago
on a mission in brazil to capture a
wanted fugitive
when we got there it tore through our
unit in seconds
the target has superhuman abilities
[Applause]
[Music]
it had the same marking you do cole
it's the birthmark what do you mean he
was born with it
it's not a birthmark means you've been
chosen
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament
world champions that dragon marking
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
[Applause]
as mortal kombat
these are your champions i'm sonia
that's kano
[Applause]
no matter how many of my people you put
in the ground
we will not fail kill them
[Music]
i am zero
get over here
you [ __ ] beauty
[Music]
in each of us there burns the fury of a
warrior
in every generation are chosen to prove
it one of you three will decide the
outcome of the tournament
three strangers
travel to the mystical realm of outworld
to defend our people against shang
and his forces of darkness
in an ancient tournament one more
victory
your soul is mine
and our world is theirs
it has begun
[Music]
[Music]
i don't need to run
[Music]
scorpion
combat begins
you